esta cop 27 en Egipto tiene una
particularidad Y es que acoge por
primera vez a tres pabellones que no
habían estado presentes en ninguna otra
de las cumbres de cambio climático de la
ONU uno de los más concurridos es este
que tengo detrás de mí el pabellón de
los niños niñas y jóvenes una población
que tiene cuatro veces más posibilidades
de sufrir efectos adversos del cambio
climático por eso es muy importante para
ellos tener esta oportunidad de estar
presentes y de alzar su voz
creciendo Yo me sentía sola porque era
la única loquita preocupada por el
planeta y ahora tener un espacio aquí en
el que ver que no estamos solos es lo
mejor del mundo
históricamente relegadas a la zona verde
de las conferencias del clima que son
zonas alejadas de donde se llevan a cabo
las negociaciones las organizaciones que
piden justicia climática se han
solidarizado y se han unido para crear
un pabellón por primera vez en una
cumbre de cambio climático de Justicia
climática
hemos tenido otros tipos de pabellones
pero nunca uno específicamente para este
tema y sin tener ese tipo de
representación pues no estamos teniendo
Las tipos de conversaciones que se
necesitan para para decirles a las
personas en poder lo que estamos lo que
queremos y lo que queremos de nuestra
comunidad que son más impactadas nuevas
voces en esta cop27 que reflejan algunos
de los puntos más críticos del
calentamiento global y del cambio
climático Como por ejemplo este pabellón
del Mediterráneo también por primera vez
en una Cumbre climática de la ONU una
región el Mediterráneo que se calienta
un 20% más rápido que la media global